I have $40,000 for you. Thank you.
This is why we surprised Fatima with
$40,000.
You need help?
Uh, you need help?
My shoes.
Okay, come with me.
Are you crying?
For you.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a saddak for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation,
you will in be reaping the reward. Click
the link and donate what you can.
Asalam alalaykum brothers and sisters
and dear friends. I came across this
video on Tik Tok. Somebody sent it to me
and I found it very interesting because
all this time from the Zionist
government as you guys know Mossad these
guys are deeply rooted in so many
governments. Like I'll be honest with
you like it's it's not farfetched to say
Zionists control the world somehow. Like
literally to a specific extent they have
made Muslims look so like as as
terrorists, evil people that we want to
kill infidels like all this false
propaganda is finally being exposed
because what they portrayed us to be is
what they are doing and what they are
really like. So they've been projecting
all this time. Here's a video of a man
who's pretending to be blind who does
social experiments and a Muslim woman
who is from Syria who has run away from
due to the war hasn't seen her family
comes across him and look what she does.
Now, of course, we're not saying that
this is only for Muslims or Muslims are
the ones are only kind to people. I'm
not saying that. The point is the
vilification. This is the true essence
of Muslim. This is what we are taught
which we're going to come to in here is
the video in let's watch for oursel and
let's see what lessons we can learn from
this.
You need help?
Uh,
you need help?
Yeah.
Who?
My shoes.
Okay. Come with me.
I hurt my legs.
My sorry me Muslim. No, come with me.
Shoes.
What's your name?
Fatima.
Where are you from?
Syria. Come.
I'll stay here. It's okay.
Sit here.
Are you crying?
You could go choose.
Yeah.
Sit here.
Are you crying
for you?
Okay.
Sorry, miss. We can shut up.
Thank you.
Size
10.
Oh, thank you.
How much were they?
Maybe $15.
Why did you buy me shoes?
My daughter $1.
She said she wants to help everyone,
whoever she can. If she knows them,
doesn't know them. We're all human.
Do you want anything else she can get
you?
Do you have change for $5 for the bus?
Maybe just a second.
I have five dollars.
Okay.
Why are you giving me your money?
In her heart, she knows that everybody's
going through something like she is, and
she was trying her best to help
everybody she can.
I want to give your mom the money back.
I can't take
She said no, keep them. You need them.
She doesn't have any more cash offer,
but if she had, she would have been
Oh, no. That's for real.
Please, Fatima. Fatima, please. Please,
please.
No.
Tell her I have
$1,000 cash.
No, no, no. For real. No,
I'm not blind.
Alhamdulillah.
This is for you.
Can you use it?
She's been through a lot. She hasn't
seen her family in over like 15 years.
And she misses her mom. What do you want
me to do with the money?
There's people more in need than this.
Are you sure?
Yes.
I need to give you the money.
Brian, can I have a message?
Please. Please tell her to use this. I I
want to give her the money.
Thank you.
You're so welcome. Please.
What's your mom's message to the world?
For everybody to be kind to each other
and love each other and nobody hate
anybody else and hopefully everybody
gets to reunite with their families and
see the people they love most.
Can I give you a hug so much?
Hug. Love you. I love you.
Okay guys, so you saw that for yourself.
Subhan Allah. It's very interesting
because not only did she go and buy him
shoes um she put the shoes on for him,
done the laces and this is basic thing
that our religion teaches us. The
prophet peace be upon him said that uh
the lowest form of faith is to move a
harmful object from the road. So we are
told by the prophet peace be upon him
that being good and kindness to others
etc. you know um
love for your brothers and sisters what
you love for yourself yeah and this is
means generally whatever you love for
someone else for yourself if you're like
I I think this is the best you want the
best for the best for yourself right you
should have the same attitude with
others and this is exactly what we saw
now obviously after this happened
something more beautiful happened what
happened is people saw this video they
came together and raised $40,000 for her
and her family this is how it went and
this is what happened when she uh was
the guy who done the experiment got in
contact with her and met her and told
her the good news. So, here is what
happened in let's watch that in come
back and learn a few more points in
I have $40,000 for you. Thank you.
This is why we surprised Fatima with
$40,000.
You need help?
Uh, you need help?
My shoes.
Okay, come with me.
Are you crying?
Who are you?
Fatima gave me her last few dollars and
bought me shoes cuz she saw that a
stranger needed help.
She doesn't have any more cash offer,
but if she had, she would have a lot.
She hasn't seen her family in over like
15 years and she was a nervous.
Tell her I have $1,000 cash.
No, no, no. For you. No.
I'm not blind.
Alhamdulillah.
But what Fatima didn't know, you raised
her over $40,000. Let's go surprise him.
Fatima.
Hi.
Thank you so much for video.
Did you see it?
Yes.
You're very kind.
Thank you so much in the family. say
about the video and that we will comment
nice.
She thanks everybody that said like the
kind something kind to her in the
comments.
Love you.
I love you too.
What's your dream?
To see her family.
Where's your family now?
Jordan. Mom and dad and sister.
How long since you've seen them?
Since like 2012.
If she could say anything to her mom,
what would she say?
Uh she loves her and may God protect her
for her.
I want you to go see your mom and your
family.
I have $40,000 cash. Thank you.
Thank you.
You're so welcome. This is for you.
Alhamdulillah.
Love you.
I love you too.
Okay guys, so you saw that for yourself.
Subhan Allah. One thing that I missed
out as well is that she was basically
the moment he said I'm not blind. She
said, "Alhamdulillah." Like like praise
be to God. She praise God, you know. And
this is what Muslims are. Like this is
our this is what we are taught, you
know. There is no this attitude of
wanting to harm others etc. In the
Quran, there are many verses, you know,
many, many verses. And there is no way
even when it comes to warfare, a lot of
people make it seem as if, oh, she's
just she's just being herself. If she
really followed true Islam, she would
not do that. No. Please show us where in
Islam in the entire Quran or literature
that tells us to be hostile to people
just because they are um disbelievers
for that matter. It doesn't. Allah in
the Quran in 60 verse 8 he says Allah
does not forbid you from being just and
kind to those who did not fought you
based on your faith and kick you out of
your houses. Allah only forbids you from
those who are attacking you. And in many
verses Allah says in the Quran repel
evil with that which is good and the one
that you have enmity you will see
friendship. So there's many many verses
like Allah says if you save a soul is so
saves all of humanity. But the Zionists,
the Zionists were putting all this lies
in the propaganda, billions spent,
billions, half a billion pounds spent on
the in on an industry to vilify Muslims
for the past 20, 30 years. The war on
terror, people going to Iraq, losing
their life only to find out those who
are in the highest shalom that are they
are the ones who are benefiting while
meeting and you are each other's neck.
And you can see this from the far right
who have been funded and paid. So just a
beautiful video just shows that of
course many people are kind, many people
there's atheists, there's Christians,
many people have kindness. The point is
though as Muslims there is no this
propaganda that they we are out there to
get you and we don't like your lifestyle
and we're against your freedoms is
absolutely bull crap because Muslims in
their countries they don't wake up and
say oh we want to take over. It's
absolutely nonsense. They want to live
their life and millions of Muslims have
been massacred through genocide and war
and we are called the terrorists. It
just doesn't make sense. But
alhamdulillah the whole world is waking
up that the Zionists were behind all of
this stuff and that the whole world is
waking up that their propaganda is over
and this is what they were doing making
us fight one another. But now because of
digital media and uh social media,
people are seeing in 4K what really is
happening and the true belief in
Muslims. If you're a non-Muslim watching
this, read the Quran. Benefit yourself,
educate yourself. Do not fall for this
hatred, bigotry of we Muslims are here
to take over and whatever it is. I hope
you guys enjoy the video and I urge you
guys to read the Quran and benefit from
inshallah. Till next time.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said whoever builds a masjid for the
sake of Allah subhanaa tala Allah will
build for him a similar house in Jenna
on that day where Allah subhanaa tala
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atom weight of good
deed we've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to Pray you built a masjid. I
never had the money to build a masjid.
Oh Allah, you helped. You gave towards
it and Allah gives you the reward of as
if you've built it. Donate now guys and
do not delay and share the video for
extra rewards.
[Music]